aoc i don't see her as latina i mean
she came out with something last week
saying that anybody who doesn't use the
term latinx should not be considered
what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
i mean are you crazy i mean latin first
of all why do we have to change our name
latina is a beautiful word by the way of
course latina is a beautiful word and
that latina can't call herself latina
anymore she has to call herself latinx
the language of my parents the language
languages my grandparents the language
that comes from spain we have to change
and all of a sudden call it latinx
because aoc
decided that we should be what the f
what
what is latinx by the way no idea i
don't even know like some think tank
some liberal think tank somewhere
decided we're going to ch why don't you
change all the irish people to irish
acts you know it's never going to stop
persian
uh you know whatever the hell you are i
don't know don't try to figure it out i
mean why do we get the ass and the crazy